[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of outdoor boys and today we are going
to be experimenting with exotic fruits
we are gonna do some awesome taste
testing here and we are at the
International supermarket H Mart and
we're gonna have a ball now in case
you're wondering why Nathan's face is
covered in bandages it's because
somebody's been picking his mosquito
bites
isn't that right Nathan yeah here we go
here we are eight smart this place has
an amazing selection of international
produce so we're gonna grab some of the
craziest stuff here and do a little bit
of taste test with some friends and it's
gonna be pretty awesome all right guys
we got Korean melon want you hold onto
that
don't let get squished and look Galia
melon oh you want to hold the Galia
melon and and here we go got some aloe
vera look at those little tiny bananas
should we go try those let's go find a
bag you know what this is this is cactus
pear we got a green guava come here
check this out do you know what that is
dragon fruit oh we got here bamboo baby
Chucky no call that banana flower you
take it out this jackfruit it's normally
huge you can see how big it normally is
and we're gonna buy a piece of that
alright guys well we got all of our
fruit let's go ahead and buy this and
we're gonna go home and fight some
friends over and do a little taste test
all right guys we're back here at the
house and we're we're getting ready to
cut these up and start taste testing
this fruit we've got the Joneses here
with us first off let's start with
something easy show you want to chop
that up first
[Music]
at the time you get the seeds off okay
who wants the piece maybe cantaloupe or
honeydew yeah honeydew well you done put
it in there all right here's a white
guava there you go guys that's what a
white guava looks like inside first time
I ever had a guava was riding a horse on
Mount Holly ocula in Maui and there was
a guava tree and I reached up picked the
fruit and ate it right on the horseback
eating was the most delicious thing ever
so the next time I saw guava tree I ran
up to it
and went to pick the fruit from it and
thousands of large knobby spiders fell
into my hair and face what do you think
really horrible amazing
lot of seeds it I'll bet it's almost
like an apple or something but a
different texture makes softer but
really hard yeah lots of them too
you guys want to do the dragon fruit
next yeah look at that it's got this
rubbery skin okay and all of this white
stuff is flesh yeah they're really good
have you had these before just cuts nice
and soft mm-hmm okay so good TV doesn't
it so much but I like this very good
problem now Levi he's got a lot of
experience with this he lived in
Cambodia for a while
well nathan is squishing the prickly
pear so I think we better we better do
the prickly pear before he destroys it
oh all right guys why don't you go ahead
and grab so that have get out of tape
Oh looks it's like eating an animal
heart when a one day my dad ate a pig
brain it's kind of a bland tip texture
which is surprising given the color I
expected to be a strong flavor so are
these like an American like prickly pear
yeah those are the prickly pear fruit no
not much not much flavor at all I mean
it's bland yeah so here's a normal
banana and here's a little baby banana
we're gonna see if they taste any
different okay yeah is sweeter than
normal banana I like that that's good
you wanna do me this is not open this is
like a fish fillet we need a rebound
fruit after that one we have a couple
done good I like that that's got a lot
of flavor to it that's more flavor than
I how do you do okay we got the
jackfruit all right so this is jackfruit
which is similar to a durian but less
pungent and smaller Spike's but it's a
massive fruit these things get like 1520
pounds really big ones you know I got a
tool for it there we go now we're
cooking with gas
watch your fingers
I know I use this hot explorer
eventually try not to destroy my cutting
board I kind of am for all of you guys
who questioned whether or not I needed a
hog splitter there you go I totally need
a hog splitter kind of spread it apart
he gives these little pods that is a pod
of flesh and inside it is a big old seed
and so you get rid of the seed and then
that now that's what you eat right there
all these things are sticky it's like
it's like butchering a pine tree why
don't you grab a piece sticky very
sticky why did you really like the
flavor that yeah that's really good I
was expecting to do mortar for some
reason I guess those things like
pineapple it reminds me of eating like
dried apples yeah but it's very sticky
all right you want to do this this is
takenoko or bamboo baby
this right here is takenoko or bamboo
baby it's the shoot of a bamboo tree and
you dig it up out of the ground and it's
fairly hard do you boil it drain the
water off and boil it again to get all
the toxins out of it that can make you
sick and this is something that's used a
lot in Asian cooking but it's actually
pretty good I've actually had this
before yes you can see right there it
looks like a bamboo inside it's got the
little compartments and everything so
this one was kind of a mean bad joke
okay takenoko really you don't you don't
really eat it raw it's it's meant to be
like stews and stuff it's kind of like
eating a cut-up potato so that's bitter
alright guys you ready for the banana
flower
this is the only fruit here I have never
easier touched I'm gonna husk it like
corn I think we're supposed to eat the
heart tell you this you peel it back in
more Dingley do bits I'm expecting
they're like candy to be in the middle
or something I this is what I got so far
kinda looks like artichoke heart on the
inside I may have removed too many
layers I'm not sure I'm sure some
Malaysian grandmas gonna yell at me on
YouTube go ahead and try a bit oh oh
that's what that case we never come out
that's gross oh it was uh oh it was like
tree sap getting poured into your mouth
only worse it was bitter bitter bitter
bitter and sticky oh well guys I hope
you enjoyed this video and got a kick
out of this there's a lot of great foods
out in there in the world give them a
try and if you like what you see here in
the outdoor boys YouTube channel don't
forget to we put out new videos every
Saturday morning also if you like this
video check out our other video where we
do taste testing survival foods and MREs
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video